Linda Popky, thank you for joining me.
How are you?
I'm great. How are you, Michael?
Wonderful. You're in Redwood City.
The air is not the best right now
because there's fires happening today.
Right?
It's smoky out there,
but we're staying inside.
We're staying inside anyway
so it doesn't really matter,
but hopefully by the time this airs,
the fires will, of course, have gone out,
and hopefully covid will be
a little bit better as well.
I have to start with your fun fact
because you played the same piano
that Billy Joel played?
I actually played the concert grand piano
that Billy Joel bought.
And I'm a classical pianist.
I do that for fun
and to keep me sane.
And I was in New York
a number of years ago
and was at the Steinway store
in not far from Carnegie Hall.
And we were annoying one of the reps.
We were playing a number of the pianos.
And then she says,
"Try this one down here."
and it had a tag on it that said Joel.
"Who's Joel?"
She said, "Do you like that?"
I said, "Yeah, Joel's got a nice piano."
She said, "Do you know who that is?"
I said, "No."
She said, "That's Billy Joel."
So, he had tagged that piano.
He bought it, and we played it
before he even got it in his house.
Okay. So, I really hope
that you didn't wash your hands
since that moment
because I know that
I wouldn't for the rest of my life.
He's one of my favorite artists
of all time.
So when I saw that fun fact,
I was blown away.
But that's just, that's wonderful.
Linda, I want to transition
to marketing and consulting,
two really interesting things
that I know very, very little about.
So I'm especially curious
for this episode.
And I'd love to start
by talking a little bit about
the role of messaging and marketing
and your ability to help
other entrepreneurs, managers, executives,
convey their message in a way
that helps them at the end win.
And whether it's sales
or bringing the right people on board
or just getting
the right messaging across.
And then we'll transition
to the organization
that you're helping run
the SAC for consulting.
So, let's start off. Linda,
Talk to me a little bit
about yourself, your journey,
and why marketing?
What is it about marketing
that really makes you excited?
So it's funny because I guess
I don't think I ever consciously said
I want to be a marketer,
but I'm creative,
and I've always been a writer.
And it just seemed to be a great way
to get things across.
And I started out, I actually
wanted to be a journalist,
and I went to Boston University
to the School of Public Communications.
And they had us write things
like obituaries
and follow town council meetings
and all that stuff.
And I said,
"This is boring."
You know, this is not gonna be
the fun stuff you see on TV
and in the movies.
So I said what can I do
that would be a little more interesting?
And I sort of wound up in advertising,
in PR, and then from there
into really marketing.
And I think ... fun is
you have people like yourself,
you have people who are entrepreneurs.
They have a wonderful product.
They have a great idea.
They really are passionate about it.
But no matter how good that is,
if you can't translate that into something
that your audience cares about,
it doesn't matter.
So we sort of have this idea if
I've got this great product and
this great idea
we're gonna be successful.
That's not always true.
A lot of, too many, really good ideas
just fall by the wayside
because we haven't been able
to get the right message
to the right person.
And it's not just having,
say in general
what's good about you,
but why do I care.
If I'm your audience,
why is that important to me?
It's not important
because you're good or
because you're smart or
because you have the right credentials.
It's because you're gonna do
something for me.
And that's what as marketers
we have to do; we have to find the WIIFM,
what's in it for me,
for your prospects, and your audience.
What was that acronym?
WIIFM: what's in it for me.
W-I-I-F-M.
I love it. Okay.
I have to dig a little bit deeper
into this concept
because, at the end of the day,
you're right.
We're working, I could be working
16, 17 hours a day very diligently
on something that I think
is really special,
Bbt then in the one minute
that I have my audience's attention,
whether it's an investor,
a person that I'm selling to,
or another employee
that I want to on board to the company,
then it doesn't work.
So, what are some of the pitfalls
that you see people make
that I should be avoiding
on my entrepreneurial journey?
So, I think one of the things that happens
is people get so passionate about it
that they want,
because something makes sense to you,
it should make sense to me as well.
And so you have to be careful.
And also, most cases
we are not the target audience
for our product.
Sometimes we are,
but sometimes the lens
that we look through,
the way we look, is not the way
that other people are going to see us.
And sometimes you have something
you're convinced is gonna be used
one way and it gets out there
and people say,
"That's great. Let's use it differently."
So, you have to be in communication
with the people that you want to,
or you think, are really going to be
benefiting from what you're doing.
And you have to have it be
a two way conversation,
not a dialogue.
So it's not like "Here's this,
here's this, here's this.
What do you think?" It's gotta be,
"Tell me what you want" etc.
Now that being said,
people don't always know what they want.
No one said to Steve Jobs,
You need to do iTunes.
You need to do an iPhone and an iPad.
He said, "Wouldn't it be great if...?"
So no one said to the folks
from Uber or Airbnb,
"We should do this."
So, but what they did is
they looked at the marketplace and said,
"Gee, hotels are that's too expensive
and they're yucky.
What if we did this?"
"Nobody wants to drive in a taxi cab.
What if we do that?"
So, they looked at what was going on
and they said,
How do we make the situation better?
So it wasn't,
Gee, I have a great technology,
let me go out and get it out to the world,
but how do I change people's lives
in a way that
they're gonna really appreciate it.
So, then what is your relationship
with entrepreneurs and executives
as they're framing their messaging
and as they're thinking about the WIIFM?
So, what I do,
and I work with all kinds of companies.
I work with large
Silicon Valley, Fortune 500 companies.
I work with
professional services people
like real estate agents and lawyers.
But I love working with entrepreneurs
because they're always
so passionate, right?
I mean they love what they're doing
or you couldn't be an entrepreneur.
And what I do is try to help them
through that initial passion
where it's like,
gee, this is great to say,
How do we get that message
out to people?
What does that really mean?
And sometimes it can be
a little painful for them
because it's like your child, right?
So, telling your child is not dressed
the way they should be.
And you're saying,
"No, I dressed them, they're great"
So yeah, it's actually
a great baby that you have,
but we might have to put them
in a little bit different outfit
to have them be the rest of the world
see how cute your kid is.
So, it's that kind of a thing.
But it's great to be able
to work with them.
Sometimes what I do
is I work with technology companies
where they're very, very smart people
and they have the right idea,
they have the right the concept.
They know that they're gonna help
their customer,
but they're so focused
on the bells and whistles,
the speeds and feeds,
and we have to turn that into benefit.
So, I will take that language
and re-frame that in a way
that their audience says,
Oh, now I get it.
Now I understand what's in it for me
and why I should pay attention to you.
Because if you can't get my attention,
and you've only got
a very short period of time.
We have such short
attention spans right now.
Everybody, I mean you think about it.
Your average commercial
that you might see on TV
or on the Internet is 10, 15 seconds.
There was a time when it was
30, 60 seconds etc.
But if you can't capture my attention
in a few seconds, I'm gone.
And so, you've got to cut
to the chase very quickly.
And so how can we do that?
And so that's what I do is I help people
take their messaging and frame it
and mold it in a way
that people like you and others can say,
"Oh, tell me more."
And then once I've got
to tell me more,
now you can go out
as an entrepreneur and say,
"Hey, try this." or
"Here's what you need to know" etc.
But if you don't get my attention,
it doesn't matter
how good your product or service is,
because I'm just not there.
Is there a way to validate this properly
without going all out on marketing spends
and sending this to the public?
So, if I want to now go
and test this messaging,
and I sit down and I say,
"Okay, Michael. I have a 20 word limit
to send to Linda
so that she would be willing
to buy my product and be on my show
20 Minutes Leaders.
How do I get her attention?"
How do I go about that process?
So here's the thing.
There's a big difference between telling one person
and telling a million people.
So what you do is
you find a good target audience,
whether it's people you know
or people you are referred to etc,
and you say,
"Hey, I think you might be
the right people for this.
Let me run this by you."
What is it? Does it resonate?
Does it make sense?
And sometimes they'll say, "Yes"
and sometimes they'll say, "No"
and sometimes they'll say,
"Well, sort of,
but here's what it is
that I think makes sense."
And then the other thing,
before you even do that, ask them.
"Hey, I've got this idea.
What do you think?
Would that make sense to you?
Who would buy this?
Would you spend money on it?
Would that, would you pay?"
Well yeah,
or maybe you should talk
to so-and-so, or not,
you know, don't. Forget it.
I mean, one of the most important projects
I did a number of years ago,
because I also do market research,
was with an entrepreneur
who had a product
in the consumer electronics space.
And he was convinced
that this was gonna be
the next big thing, right?
And so he hired us to do some research.
And we went out
and conducted focus groups.
And we looked at this thing
inside, outside, backwards, forwards.
And people basically said,
I would never buy this thing. Why?
And so we had to sit him down and say,
"You know, there really is not a market
for your product."
And he was kind of unhappy
because we didn't just tell him
his baby was ugly,
we told him he shouldn't have
the baby at all, right?
So, he was sort of not real happy ...
but I felt that we had saved him
millions of dollars
'cause had he not done that,
he would've invested in this thing
and gone out and produced it.
He was gonna,
he had a factory in Asia
that was gonna make this stuff.
He would've wound up
with a warehouse full of these things
and been out a lot of money
and a lot of time and effort.
So sometimes, you learn things
you may not like,
but it's really helpful to know.
So, through the lenses of marketing
and through coming in
as a third party independent
and you're actually helping sometimes
uncover a lot of the really the dirt
of what's happening, right?
It's not just that maybe
the messaging is not right,
but maybe the product is not right.
Do you find that most people approach you
when they have a problem?
Or when they're, because it sounds to me
like you're the type of person
I would go to when I realize
that I'm not able to do this myself.
I'm trying and I'm not succeeding, right?
You know there's a couple things.
So sometimes people come in
'cause they say,
"Hey, we got to a certain point
and we're stuck."
And very often you get some people
that like what you have.
You get to here,
and you want to get to here,
and you need to figure out
how do you break through.
So that could be it.
But sometimes people come
because they say,
"We've got this great thing,
we've got this great product,
and I've got this idea.
And we need your help
to get it out there.
And how do we make this thing
be fantastic?
We haven't ...
We're just not sure how to get
from point A to point B"
And that's what I would say
is maturity in an entrepreneur,
because there are
some entrepreneurs that say,
"I know everything. This is great.
I'm convinced I have the backing.
I have this. I have that.
I know what the right message is."
And sometimes they're right.
And more often than not,
they kind of get a little bit push backed
because they think they know,
and they haven't asked.
It's all a one way street;
they haven't had that dialogue.
Right. Okay,
so talk to me a little bit
about consulting overall.
So before we dive into the organization
the you're helping run, the SAC,
I'd love to understand a little bit better
the role of a consultant
and why that is something
that is specifically interesting to you?
So, I spent a lot of time
in Silicon Valley.
I worked for Sun Microsystems
for a number of years.
And I left Sun in the early 2000s
and people would send me jobs, listings.
"Hey, you should do this.
You should do that."
And I'd look at it and say,
"I don't want to work for them.
I don't want to do that."
So, I sort of fell into consulting
because a friend of mine said,
"Well why don't you go
check this job out here?"
And I said,
"I don't think that's right for me."
But I did. And they said,
"Well, no, no, no.
We don't want to hire you,
but we'd love to bring you
in on a consulting project.
Would you be interested?"
And I said,
"Sure, why not"
And so what I found that's interesting
about consulting is,
one of the things I hate about
being in a company
is you sit in meetings
and you have to go through
all the corporate stuff
and the political things.
As a consultant, they say,
"We want you here to do something.
Can you help us with this?"
You come in. You do it.
You provide expertise.
And then you leave.
You're not there for all the other
ongoing things.
You're not trying to climb
the corporate ladder.
You're not trying to be
politically astute and all that.
And so, it's fun.
And then the other thing is
I get to work
with a lot of different people.
So, I get bored if I'm doing
the same thing all the time.
So I can be working with five, six,
seven, eight clients at the same time.
Not at the exact same moment,
but after I finish with you,
I'm gonna talk to this one
and then I'm gonna talk to that one.
And so it mixes things up
and it keeps you sharp.
But a consultant,
a good consultant, comes in
and brings their expertise
and helps you understand
how to get to the next level
without making you dependent on them
as if it's kind of like a crutch.
So, it's not that we're there to say,
"Hey, you need to keep hiring me
and hiring me." but,
"I'm here to help you solve a problem
or exploit an opportunity or whatever.
And once I get you set,
then you go on
and we go on to something else."
And so that's what I think,
and that's the difference
between a consultant and a contractor.
We have in Silicon Valley
we have a lot of contractors
which is great.
They come in, they get paid by the hour,
they do what needs to be done.
They might be there for years.
That's perfectly fine.
Consultants, we don't really charge
by the hour;
we charge by the value we provide
by the project.
And we come in,
we provide this level of expertise,
and then we leave.
And we go on and help someone-
As a consultant yourself, do you bring in
the expertise that you have
specifically in marketing and messaging
and through the book that you've written,
The Leverage2Market,
is that the main consulting that you do?
I do. So, a lot of what I do
is around marketing,
and everything from strategy
and branding and positioning.
I did a lot of work
with channels and partners
in my time on the corporate side.
So I work with people doing that.
Marketing intelligence,
which is like research.
But then I also work with entrepreneurs
and small business people to say,
"Let me coach you if you're having trouble
figuring out where you are
and what you need to do."
So, sometimes I work with people
just to help them
get their own ideas together
and help them move forward with that.
And then the other thing I do
is because I'm creating
a lot of content today is
not only do I create content for clients,
but I also edit other people's content.
So, whether that would be white papers
or promotional materials,
but I'm doing a lot of book,
either book proposals or book manuscripts.
And in the midst of this pandemic,
for whatever reason,
everybody's gotten around to writing
that project they had put off for years.
So, I'm getting lots and lots of projects
coming in about people saying,
"I finally finished the book.
I need someone to look at it."
And again, I can help translate
to the audience,
but I'm also good at saying, "That comma
didn't appear where it should be"
And "Yeah, you used ...
a dangling participle there.
So, let's fix the grammar"
So, all of those things.
So, I talk about marketing above the noise.
All those things that kind of are there
that aren't exactly right,
they're all noise.
And so, when you want to get out
and talk to someone,
you want to get rid of all the noise.
It's like static, right.
- I love it
Remember an old fashioned radio,
which may be before your time,
but there was static, right, and AM.
You want to get rid of all the static
so that I can hear you and
we can communicate directly.
And so that's what I do
is I help get rid of all that static
and all that noise
so you can reach your customers
more effectively.
Right. And I think it's very funny
that you mentioned that everybody
got around to writing books.
I'm actually publishing a book myself
next week that I got writing
throughout these covid times.
But I want to make sure
we also have enough time
to talk a little bit about this group SAC.
So Society ...
remind me again the exact name?
Society for the Advancement of Consulting.
So, Alan Weiss is kind of the guru
of independent consulting.
He's my mentor.
And he had created this association
17 years ago.
And he wanted to give
independent consultants
a way to get together
and work with each other.
And it went on and on and on,
but he didn't put a lot of time in it
'cause he had a lot
of other things going on.
So, two and a half years ago he came to me
and a woman who's become
my business partner
in Southern California, and he said,
"I don't really have the time
to put in this. Would you take it over?"
And we said,
"Okay. Why not?"
So, we took it over.
We blew away everything
that was old fashioned
and labor intensive
and took time on your part.
Made it all online, membership, etc.
Before there was a pandemic,
we were early Zoom users.
So, we knew
...
And we said, "We're gonna do webinars"
And what kind of value
could we add to our members.
So our motto is growth by association.
So, how do you grow by being associated
if you're an individual person.
How do you grow by having
the right people around you.
So, we do webinars.
We do online workshops.
We do all kinds of,
We have special interest groups
like around people who are interested
in supply chain and non-profits
and technology.
And we've grown the organization
so that we have,
now we have members in 14 countries.
So, it's been a lot of fun.
And people say to us,
"Wow. This has really been more
than we ever thought"
And they're across all kinds
of different consulting: OD and technology
and marketing and finance
and IT and you name it.
So, it's all kinds of interesting things.
And this year, actually this fall,
we normally have our annual meeting
every year in New York City.
And we had space on a hotel
in New York City
and we moved it out to 2021.
So, we're doing it virtually.
And here's the thing
that's really interesting is, you've got to
as an entrepreneur, you've got to say,
"Here's where we are
and here's how I'm gonna make
something happen."
We said,
"Okay, we can't be in New York.
We're sorry about that.
We're sad.
Okay, now we're done."
We have people in all over the world.
We're gonna have an expanded day
where we're gonna start
very early in the morning for us
here in California,
in New York, and we're gonna have sessions there.
Sessions in the middle of the day
for North America.
Later in the day for Pacific Rim.
So, no matter where you are,
there will be things happening
in your timezone.
We're gonna be able to get experts
that wouldn't come to New York.
And then we're gonna record everything
on Zoom and archive it
so you don't have to sit, Michael,
from 6:00 in the morning
till 10:00 at night.
You pick what you want
and you just watch it whenever.
So, this is happening in October.
We've already doubled the number of people
who would've come to New York
and we still have two months out.
So that's what I mean about you see,
okay, the whole thing about lemons
and making lemonade.
We can't be there in person.
How do we make this even better?
And I think that's what really makes
a successful entrepreneur,
is you say,
"Hey, this is not what I thought
I was getting into,
but given where I am, how do I take it
and do the best I can with it?"
Wow. I think that's just remarkable.
Linda, I want to take this time
to thank you for your generosity
and for all the insights for this.
But before we leave,
I have to ask you my favorite question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Three words.
I think number one is creative.
I'm a writer, I'm a musician, etc,
so I love creating things.
Number two is resourceful.
I take what's given to me
and we turn it around and do what we can.
And number three is determined.
You can't knock me down.
I'll get back up and then figure out
where we go from here.
So creative, resourceful, determined.
That's me.
I love it. I simply love it.
Thank you very, very much.
Oh thank you, Michael.
All right.
Take care.
Yeah